the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season on Game of Thrones hey
guys so before I start within your
theory I want to announce a giveaway the
price of this giveaway is $100 Amazon
gift card in description below I have
provided a link and that link will take
you to the website called gleam and the
page will look something like this now
once you go to the website it will show
you some ways that you can enter this
giveaway it will be asking you to
subscribe to my channel and watch your
video and more interest you make the
bigger chance you're getting to win a
giveaway so yeah leave a like subscribe
or comment something nice
[Music]
and also I want to congratulate Josh for
winning the previous giveaway for
winning $50 Amazon giftcard I wish you
all good luck okay guys now let's move
on today's topic in this video I'm going
to talk about fate of the red woman who
is approximately 400 years old I'm going
to talk about the fate of Melisandre in
the upcoming season
now if Sandra's fate in season 7 based
on leaked plot and the events that are
supported by leaked photos will be more
than exciting now Sandra will most
likely have a few huge encounters in
first one she might get killed while on
the second encounter Alessandra will in
my opinion determine fate of the
Brotherhood without banners Melisandre
will play a much bigger role in the last
eight season was the Great War actually
come but she will also play a huge role
in the upcoming season as she has been
doing so far
so beside a few encounters in this video
you will also be introduced to the
theory in which most Andrea will almost
the whole season be at Winterfell hiding
behind her true form in favour to stay
by John's side for the Great War so
without further ado let's just jump into
it last time is so Melisandre in
previous season she was exiled from the
north by Jon Snow for her crime after
which she is seen riding south
now that Melisandre is heading south and
if you watch my previous videos you
would know that she will encounter the
Brotherhood without banners but let's
first focus on encounter between male
Sanjay and Arya who is heading north
there's one short scene from HBO's
official teaser of a new season which
actually gave us a lot there's only one
quick scene of Farian horseback wearing
north clothes in my opinion it's seen on
farias arrival at finn felt after all
these years of suffering she finally
came back home and it's her face
expression Mottola motion senate after
arya told the jaqen H'ghar who she
really is and there she is going
the girl is Arya Stark of Winterfell and
I'm going home it was easy to assume
even before official teaser was
published the Tory will reunite with
bran and Sam Sann Winterfell and that we
are going to have a full stark reunion
before that big reunion has
or I will have an interesting trip to
Winterfell full of the encounters as
I've already said in previous videos my
first prediction is that on her way home
I will finally need her diary from
Amelia just like leaks plots as as well
but while it's going to be a hard Malik
scene it won't be the most important
encounter that we're going to see now
and rescanning south and arias heading
north supported with most Andrews
prophecy that she told to re-injured
season I see a darkness in you and in
that darkness eyes staring back at me
brown eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes
that it will shut forever we will meet
again surely they'll meet again our
jaded shuttle of these eyes the only
remaining thing of that prophecy to come
true is no Sandra meeting Aria again in
my opinion messengers prophecy will come
true in the first episodes of the
upcoming season but a question is how
the meeting is going to end well we know
aria and we know how much she is
dedicating on decreasing the name from
her Achilles and we also know that
Melisandre is on that list which gave me
a thought that the possible outcome of
that encounter could be Arya killing
Melisandre whereupon Lord of Light would
bring her back to life since she has
many things you have to do this is only
a possibility but a sure thing is arias
arrival at Winterfell
most likely in the middle of season 7
now there comes a meeting which is going
to be very important for future events
in the upcoming season a meeting between
us and rain the Brotherhood without
banners meeting which will in my opinion
resulted the Brotherhood joining John in
his mission which is confirmed by a lot
of leaked photos and leaked plot as well
but there is not stated that is going to
happen because of Melisandre by my
theory Melisandre will tell to Barry
Cantor's that John is the one the one
that is promised the one that Lord of
wise brought back to life as their
conversation continues and as my theory
continues now Sandra will convince
barrack and Taurus that John is the
prince that was promised and since we
all know that both of them obey commands
of the Lord of Light I can assume that
it won't even take too long for
Melisandre to convince them to go
North to the wall and help John in his
mission a mission in which doors will
die mission that will resulted whole
Westeros knowing about the real threat
resulted almost every Lord sending their
armies to the north I think that I don't
even have to tell you that Varrick and
tourists along with hounds they'll
definitely go to the north after this
encounter with no Sandra's since beric
Dondarrion and tours believe in the Lord
of Light
besides Barry has died six times only to
be revived at all six times by tourists
of mears prayers to the Lord of Light in
my opinion the Brotherhood without
banners will join John at Castle black
since they will travel by the land while
John will lead his team with his mission
by the sea in a boat as confirmation for
this statement we have like photo in
which we clearly can see that John
doubles during injury push the boat and
then together away after they've already
met the dragon stone John and his team
will travel by the scene both meaning
that they won't take a step on the
ground before they make it to the world
meaning that they will travel to
eastwatch-by-the-sea as I've already
said in previous videos but now we have
confirmation for my statements as you
could see really photos that appeared a
few days ago in themes black sand beach
on Vic's Shores which should be their
landing a seaside castle which belongs
to the Nights Watch in case you didn't
watch my previous videos
eastwatch-by-the-sea is the castle and
port located at the far eastern end of
the wall where the ball drops into an
inlet of the Shivering sea called the
bay of seals east which by the sea is
one of only three mile castles left on
the bowl along with Castle black and the
shadow tower in the novel's it's
specified that Stannis Baratheon also
lanane with his forces at
eastwatch-by-the-sea when he came to the
wall to save the Nights Watch however
John along with Jorah Davos and injury
as I've already said will sail to the
east by the see the castle located at
the eastern end of the wall where from
they're going to proceed west along the
north side of the wall until they reach
Castle black Castle black will be the
place when the John will gather his team
guess why could also be a place in which
the Brotherhood without banners
is going to become the part of John
steam whereupon they will go on bite
hunting hope you're in with John will
gather his team and go beyond the wall
to get you right in favor to prove the
rest of Westeros that the real war is
just about to come a tear in which John
and almost died while benjin and tourist
are going to die you can click polish
you to check out and keep it in mind
that the steering is confirmed by a lot
of leaked photos while in my opinion
loss and river water days disappear for
the most of season
there's also theory floating around
about Melisandre constant presence at
Winterfell according to this theory now
Sansa will take off her necklace along
with her beauty and youth with it and
reveal her true form which is a frail
old woman in order to stay by Jon Snow
as the theory goes Melisandre in her
true form will return to the north to
Winterfell
since someone actual knows how she
really looks like and stay by John's
side for the Great War you have to known
that this is only a theory supported
with absolutely nothing so it might end
might not come true but it certainly
seems like an interesting theory so yeah
in my opinion Melisandre will utter
those two encounters probably disappear
for the most of the season whereupon she
will reappear dramatically I don't near
the end of the upcoming season or in the
very beginning of the last eighth season
but it's only my opinion I could be
wrong Melisandre might be included in
every single episode but I just don't
see that way let me know your opinion on
all of this in the comment section down
below do you agree with my theory in
which all credits for the Brotherhood
without banners
joining Jon's mission are going to
Melisandre or do you think they would
support Jon anyway do you think the
targa might try to kill Melisandre once
they meet each other since she isn't
Hercules or do you think that no matter
Melisandre is prophecy they won't even
meet each other also give me your
opinion and theory in which Melisandre
would return to Winterfell in her true
forming favor to stay close to Jon Snow
and to be able to help him want the
Great War come and don't forget to
participate in my new giveaway in which
you have a chance to win $100 Amazon
gift card once again all you have to do
is basically to subscribe and click on
the link in description
lo hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next
[Music]
you
you
[Music]